we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
we're going to our go to our next caller
now who is joining us from the 4 to 3
area code caller in 4 2 3 what's your
name and where are you calling from
today
well I'm Cameron I'm calling from a
Madisonville Tennessee all right what's
on your mind today
I was just wondering uh in your personal
opinion what do you think that England
should do in response to the latest
terror attack you're talking about a law
enforcement response or in terms of
whether it's surveillance or what what
more specifically are you are you asking
about I guess I guess more SOVA of a law
enforcement and security look well
there's going to be you're going to need
to decide they do to it you're going to
need to decide at some point whether
this one incident that took place at a
concert venue right an ariana grande
show does that mean that you're going to
significantly change the way security is
done at these events and you probably
would apply it also to sporting events
because it's a similar sort of security
apparatus similar types of facilities
are you going to further inconvenience
people by creating a perimeter around
the venue beyond which beyond where it
currently is and for example here in
Boston Massachusetts at Fenway Park some
years ago the security perimeter around
some parts of the stadium was moved out
from the stadium doors out to actually
create a pedestrian street which is it
is Yaqui way or is it Lansdowne its
Yawkey Way and they're even talking
about closing down land sounds too
because now there's a new terrorist
tactic which is to drive a car down a
crowd a group of people and then yeah
been against against that so there's
gonna have to be some decision made
about that right and I don't know where
I come down on that because on the one
hand just because 22 people have been
tragically killed at this at this
concert the risk of being killed at a
concert by a terrorist attack is still
almost zero effectively so do you want
to in a way say hey yes we are
are terrorized by this and now we're
going to shake up our security response
because of this one incident or are you
better off saying you know what we're
not actually going to do that we might
scale up public Co CCTV camera
surveillance we might increase the use
of other methods I would hesitate though
to go in the direction of scaling up
bulk surveillance because we've we've
learned in the United States that it
doesn't really work at preventing these
types of incident so I think it's a
tough thing and what do you think they
should do oh well as you said it would
further inconvenience people to put up
further security like that but there
should be some type of screening that
could be done I mean their security is
very tight at these of things yeah but
again remember this took place I found
it very rnu yeah and the problem I have
is if you move the perimeter another
hundred feet away from the venue when
the event gets out you'll still have the
same crowd of people going from a
secured area to a non secured area it'll
just be another hundred feet further
from the front doors we also talked
about this the other day but this venue
doubles as a train station too so if you
are travelling in and out of there for a
completely different reason
you're not even attending the concert
you can't really impede their travel
yeah yeah it's very very difficult and I
wish I had an answer but but
unfortunately I don't know what it is
that you do appreciate the call though
great to hear from Mississippi just
already talking to you man
thanks so much appreciate it